police and protesters fight in the
montenegrin capital of cetinay
demonstrations against the inauguration
of the new head of the serbian orthodox
church
fascism fascism pure fascism their
sectarian gang
they threw tear gas at us for no reason
there were not over 50 hundred of us in
the center in front of the monastery
they threw tear gas all the time and we
didn't see anything montenegro declared
independence from serbia in 2006
following years of ethnic violence and
political turmoil triggered by the
breakup of the former yugoslavia but the
serbian orthodox church still represents
the country's dominant religion and
cetine the old serbian capital remains a
cultural center for serbians inside
montenegro the ceremony to inaugurate a
new church leader reopening old wounds
it's difficult to fight the serbian
priests who killed half of yugoslavia
montenegrins who opposed ties with
serbia say the serbian orthodox church
does not serve their interests and is
influenced by belgrade
protesters set up roadblocks to the
monastery to keep church and state
dignitaries away
but failed to stop the ceremony the new
church leader acknowledged the deep
divisions
oh prostitute
forgive us for a lot of inconvenience
and divisions seen here since last night
these divisions were artificially
provoked and we have done everything to
prevent them and to remove them but it
will take us a long time
nearly a third of montenegro's 620
thousand people consider themselves
serbs some refuse to acknowledge
montenegro's independence
and oppose montenegrins who want an
independent orthodox church to replace
the serbian one
rival political parties stoke tensions
by backing activists on either side of
the controversy
the ascension of a new religious leader
now a flashpoint for ethnic tensions in
an ongoing conflict over national
identity
al-jazeera
earlier i spoke to zlatko vujovic who is
a professor of political science at the
university of montenegro he says there
is a political element which is driving
opposition to the bishop's inauguration
this is for example what was uh
happening in the in portugal in satania
today and yesterday is just a new match
in a series between the pro-russian and
pro-serbian forces on one side and from
montenegro and western forces
on other side regarding the the future
of the country because the serbian
orthodox church represent the
the strongest
proxy of russia in montenegro and proxy
of russia and serbia and the additional
problem addition of that is uh
increasing the tensions and the conflict
in montenegro is that serbian order
church after the latest parliamentary
election
controlled the government there are two
orthodox churches in montenegro uh one
during the orthodox church that is not
uh accepted uh and uh by other orthodox
churches and serbian of the church and
actually the uh
the leaders of opposition the current
government they actually said openly
that the serbian orthodox church was a
part of the pre-electoral campaign but
also
about was part of negotiation about
the government who is going to be the
minister and actually the serbian author
church controls the main
number of the ministers in the
government so actually the president is
uh right when he says that actually the
serbian orthodox church is controlling
the government